今日はダンマパダの 三十三番目と三十四番目を一緒に説明いたします
パンデナンチャペランチッタンドラカンダンニワレヤン
ウジュンカロティメダーヴィーウスカローヴァテジャナン
三十四番目 ワーリジョーヴァタレキットオーカモーカタウムバトー
パリパンダティダンチッタンマーラデイヤンパータヴェー
というところで えーと
今日そんなに難しい偈ではございません
パンデナンの言葉見てください
パンデナンチャペランチッタン
それ心の状況なんですね
パンデナンっていうのは
パンデティっていうのはこの揺れるということなんですね
振動するというか 揺れると震えるというね
まあ震えるというとまあ怖いということになりますけど
まあそういったわけでもなくて
まあ落ち着かなくて いつでもまあ揺れている
チャパランというのはなかなか日本語で何と言いますかね
チャパランは まあどうにもならないという
当てにならないという意味なんですけどね
信頼できないというかね
同じ意味ですぐ変わるということで
当てにならない 信頼できないという
で チャパラン チッタンというのは心は
心はもういつでも揺れていて
まあどうしようもないもので
当てにならないと ドラカン
これを守ろうとしても全くもガードできないんですね
ダンニワレヤ それから心は制御しがたいという意味で
まあ制御といったっても
この心がやってるくだらんこと
悪いこといろいろありますね
それは知ってはいるんですけど
どうしてもそれをやめさせてもらうことはできないんですね
そういう心ですよと だから心の状況
まあいつでもまあビクビク
ビクビクビクと まあもう揺れている
そこで落ち着きがないんですね
で チャパラン もう当てにならない
もうという状態で チャパランというのは何か日本語の訳があると思いますけどね
えーと 何でしょうかね
チャペラ まあこっちはまあ動揺する
浮き世ですか 軽率 軽率ですかね
これが 出た？ 不動のとか軽率
軽率で読み方は？ 軽装の
軽装 まあ軽装かな 軽装ってなんか分からない
どんな字ですか 難しい字
手偏に口つかって  これで
それから動揺と これはこれ不動？ はい
不動の  不動 不動といってもあの
浮くという感じですね
動かないっていうんじゃないんです
軽躁 だからなんか分かりやすい単語がないね
普通で私が知ってる日本語でも当てにならないというね
信頼できん 当てにならんという
それで心っていうのはまあ揺れていて
もう不動の 不動という性格が特色で
いわゆる当てにならないもので
それで でもまた守りにくい
ドゥーラックハン ドラックハン
守りにくい だからいつでも揺れてるんだったら
当てにならないんだったら
もう守らなくちゃいけないでしょ
例えば子供なんかはもう全くその性格なんですね
まあちょっとしたことにもすぐビクビクしちゃうし
怯えたりするし 不安定になるし
ほんの少々のことで そこで子供とは全然何の約束も何もできんでしょうね
小さい時はこれこれやるのとはいと言ったっても
すぐもうやってくれないし
別なことをやるし 今日はお菓子食べなくていいでしょうと言ったらはい
いいですよと言ったら
もうもうすぐまた要求するんですね
で 忘れちゃって で そういう感じで
もうもう当てにならない
ですからこそ 子供をちゃんと我々大人が守ってあげなくちゃいけないでしょうね
どうかする時でもちゃんと手をつなげて
もう大人が気をつけないと
自分では自分を守るということはしない
だから だから子供と同じですから
やはり守るべきなんですよ
子供にどうぞ勝手に遊んでください
道路のところでということはもうとんでもない話でしょうね
そんなことしてたらどうするかわからない
ですから 子供たちに用意している公園でちゃんとフェンスがあって
ちゃんとその中に入れて鍵をかけて
どうぞ勝手に遊んでくださいと言わなくちゃいけない
外へ出たくたってもフェンスが高いんだからまあ登れないし
そういう風にも安全な状況を作ってあげなくちゃいけない
子供には なぜならば 約束は守らない
とにかく 道路を渡るなよと言ったっても
もうボール遊びしているとすぐ渡ってしまう
それは子供に期待することはできない
このチャパラっていうのはそういうことなんです
当てにならない で それでちょっとしたことに怯えたり怖くなったりする
ほんのちょっとのことに
だから この心の特色を理解したければ
その小さな子供なんか観察すると
いくらかわかると思いますが
[咳払い]で 守るべきなのに
そういうどうしようもないだらしない心だからね
信頼できないんだから
あてにならないんだから守るべきなんですけど
ドゥラッカン なかなか守りきれない
ドゥンニマーリャンというのはもう制御することなんですね
あれやってはいけない
これやってはいけないと心に言わなくてはいけないんですが
これができないんです
だから揺れる不動の心を
心がどうしてもやっていることは危険なものばっかしで
幼稚園の子供は一人で道路で歩けちゃうと
歩かせると 必ずもやっていることは全部やってはいけないことなんです
これはどうにもならないんですよ
何か面白いことを見たら
すぐそちらに飛びかかっちゃうし
で 信号 もしかするとちゃんと目に見えないかもしれませんし
あの信号を変えるボタンがあったっても
手がそこまでいかないし
で そういういろいろ危険なことをする
一応道路を渡ろうとしたところで
もう車の人がそれ見てすぐ車を停まっても
また走って元に戻ったり
また戻ろうとしたりして
また別な車にぶつかる可能性もあります
だから何するかわからないんです
だからそういう心境だから
やることは大体やめさせた方がいいんです
いわゆる制御した方がいいんです
で 同じく我々の心も制御しなくてはいけないんですけど
これがなかなか難しいと
で 仏教の違う それは心の説明で
心はそういうものであると仏教は言う
お釈迦様が言うんですよ
それにいろいろ反対意見があるかもしれませんですけど
一応お釈迦様の考え方はそういう考え方
心っていうのはどうしようもない
もうだらしない もうとんでもないもので
全然成長させるとかね
制御するとか もうどうにもならん
難しいと で そういえば一般の知識人の反論は 「
ああ そうか だったらしょうがないんだ」ということで
すごい品格よくその状況を認める
で 日本のテキストやら本やら文学から見ても
よくよくある道徳的な発言は
この人間はどうしようもない
だからいいんじゃないかと
だから大体間違い失敗っていうのは
美化するんですね そうでないと映画にもならないし
ドラマにもならないし
それでよくわかっていると
人間というのは弱いもんで
どうにもならないんだということを
それは俗世間にある知識人の道徳観で
そこで仏教ではまたちょっと違う立場が取るんですね
で ウジュンカロティ メーダーヴィ
だからメーダーヴィ 智慧がある人が
そのどうしようもない心をウジュンカロティ
しっかり伸ばしてまっすぐにさせるんだと
ウジュンというのはまっすぐという意味で
別にしっかりするという意味なんです
いわゆる強化する 強くする
しっかりする それがメーダーヴィ
智慧のある人が 知識人は
智慧のある人が あのどうにもならない
どうしようもない心を
しっかりと調教して制御して
しっかりしたものに育て上げる
で 俗世間と仏教の違う考え方
分かれるところはそちらにあるんです
俗世間の人に 「心っていうのはだらしないでしょうね
すぐすぐ考え方が変わるでしょう」って言ったら 「
そうでしょうね 考えてみれば
だからどうしようもない
そんな気にしなくていいんじゃないんですか」ということで
そこでもうカッコつけるんです
わかっているんだと 何でもという
だから悪をなくそうとかね
良いことをしよう そんなもう出しゃばったことをしなくたっていいんじゃないんですかと
というのは俗世間の考え方です
そういう状況にはめげないというところは仏教の考え方で結構違うんです
世間では だから悪を認めるということはすごいかっこいいと
と思っていて そこで仏教は分かれますね
ブッダの思考は ブッダっていうのは
だからどうしようもないんじゃなくて
だから直すんだよと 手を上げるんじゃないよと
いくらもう難しいと思っても
難しいのはもう一般人よりもブッダ
お釈迦様が分かっているんです
心って何ものかということは
世間で誰一人もいまだ勝って説明できてないんだから
ブッダ以外は だから全然他参考文章も何もないんです
心について勉強しようと思っても
別なテキストでもね 別な角度で勉強した方が理解しやすいし
心についてあの人はこう語っている
この人はこう語っている
あの人はまた別な立場でこう語っていると
そうやっていろいろ人の考え方を集めて揃ってみたら
ああ なるほど こういうことかということが我々にとっては勉強しやすいんですけど
世の中で心について勉強して研究して書いているものっていうのは一つもありません
何かそのような本はありますけど
読んでみたら別に心の状況を説明しているわけじゃないんです
いわゆる問題ははっきり発見していないんです
心というそういう働きをしっかりと明確に発見して
それからそちらについてどういうものかというふうな説明はお釈迦様の教えの中でしかないんです
それも例えば また仏教というのは
いろんな哲学を通して枝分かれになって発展していきましたけど
どうなりますか 心の説明はしないことになったんですね
仏教の大変な難しい学派がありまして
この唯識というね すべて心だけですと
物質は存在しないんだと
識のみと あれが結構難しいんですよ
勉強しましょうとも 勉強しようかなと思ったっても
唯識派の人々の考え方なんかはどうもすごく難しいんです
だったら その学派の専門分野は心の説明をすることなんです
だって唯識論だから その学者
学派の昔のそういう知識人の先生方は一つだけやってないことがあるんです
それが心の説明なんです
[笑い]まあできないとなればね
これは我々にできることではありません
と言えば それでそれで十分ですけど
それでもなく全て心のみですと
物質的な世界っていうのは心のプロジェクションであって
投影するものであって
心が外に自分を投影するんであって
実際はないんだよと それで心について語っていると勘違いするんですよ
みんな あるいは心がこういうことをやっている
こういうことをやっていると言っているだけで
心ってどういうものかという説明じゃないんです
心は六識に分かれますよとかね
眼耳鼻舌身ともうまな識と阿頼耶識って七識でしたっけ
七つに分けられ では心は何なのかと
それ説明じゃないんです
その説明はないし ただもうあれこれとは言っているんです
それで全部終わるんですよ
で なんで心はそうやってずっと働くかというと
阿頼耶識という潜在に寝ている絶対意識化できない
全くも理解できない 意識化できない阿頼耶識という潜在意識がありまして
その中でエネルギーが溜まっているんだと
エネルギーっていうのはビージャーというんですけど
このカルマビージャーというふうな言葉
サンスクリット語使ってますけど
なんとかわからない 日本語で何言うかと
種みたいなものがチクチクしていて
それの刺激でマナ識という心が生まれて
そこから眼耳鼻舌身の中で識が生まれるんだと
そうすると見えた 聞こえたとかね
人間がいるんだ 象がいるんだとか
人が勝手にそうやって誤解するんだと
で 象がいるんだと言ったら
そこで感情が生まれてきて
象っていうのはかっこいいなと思っちゃうと欲が生まれて
この欲がまた種として阿頼耶識にまた入り込んじゃうんだと
それでやがてまたその種がまた認識を作り出すんだと
作り出しちゃうと もうその時もう見たもの聞いたものから
また種が心の中に入ってくるんだと
いうことで 無限にそうやって心は回転するんだよという
だから無限に心が回転するんだということは
もう理屈で説明しようと思ったらそれは言ってます
心の中に 阿頼耶識に種があって
いっぱい 種のせいで阿頼耶識がちょっとイライラ状態になっちゃって
マナ識という心が生まれて
マナ識から六識というものが生まれていく
六識っていうのは眼耳鼻舌身の
いわゆる私たち知っている意識世界
考えたり見たり 聞いたり
味わったり 嗅いだり 体に触れたりする六識が我々知っている意識世界
それがマナ識という我々無意識世界からもう生み出すと
マナ識も我々にわからないんですけど
もっと裏に阿頼耶識っていうものがあるんだと
それは決してもう認識できない
それでその中に種が入ってそうこうだから
種が阿頼耶識をちょっとイライラさせて
それで阿頼耶識からマナ識というものが生まれてやって
マナ識から六識 なんとか生まれてきて
六識っていうのは認識だから
認識しちゃうと どうして我々は花を見ると楽しくなるわ
ゴミを見るともう気持ち悪くなるわという感情が当然生まれるでしょうに
その感情がまた種として阿頼耶識に沈んでいく
ということで 自己回転するプロセスであると
それは心の説明ですかね
それは心の説明じゃないんです
では違いますかということは言えませんだけど
違うことを説明しているんでしょうか
別に違うことを説明してるわけじゃないんですけど
論理厳密な心は何ものかという説明にはそういうこと入ってません
一応心はまず知ったという前提で喋っているんです
みんな知ってるでしょうという前提で語っているんです
だから読む人は ああそうか
俺の心はそういう働きかというふうに理解するしかないんです
それで大体世間は納得していますけど
私は納得いかないんです
それだけで なんで前提自分勝手に作らなくちゃいけないんですかね
そういう風にこの一つ前提としてあるという風にして哲学する
語るということは ブッダはしないんですよ
だから私に言われても
他宗教 哲学などなど批判するなよと
私は批判してないんです
私は仏教のブッダの教えを説明しているだけで
だからもうブッダの教えはまるっきり知らない世界だから
世界が知ってる概念から始めなくちゃいけないんです
だからブッダの教えでは
この前提で何か決まってるんではないか
それが何やというふうに喋り方はお釈迦様はしない
全くもしない それはもう断る
それは無知なやり方やと
例えばもう二千年かけて人間が魂について語ってきたとする
いろんな学説は出てくる
魂は長いんだ 短いんだ
青いだ 黄色いだとかね
ヌルヌルしているんだとか
いろんなものいるんですよ
いえ ヌルヌルしてない
結構硬いものだとかね
あるいはつかめない空気のようなものだ
いえいえ つかまりますよとか
いくらでも言えますよ
ある人は魂は青いだ ピンク色だと言っちゃうと
ある人は いえ 違います
魂は透明だと 言うと 私は世間にある魂論をバカにしてると思うでしょ？違うんです
そういう学説はあるんです
実際に 青いだ ピンクだ
黄色いだとか言ってる
で 巨大に大きいんだとか
親指ぐらい小さいんだとかね
で だから本当に勉強してほしいんですよ
世の中の考え方を批判するなよと私に言う前に
世の中の考え方を勉強したらどうですかね
だからそういう学説はあるんです
魂について 無限に広げるものやと
いえ 違いますよ 魂には制限あるんだよと
という対立する学問考え方あります
魂は時間的に無限やという人もいるんです
いわゆる永遠であると
それに反対して ある人々はそうはなりませんと
いくらなんでも魂にも寿命があるんだと
もう長いことは長いんだけど
もうもうもう頭がおかしくなるほど魂の寿命は長いんだけど
やっぱりエネルギーですから
やがて消えるという人もいる
それで これで三年間 三千年もそういう考え方があったんですよ
三年 三千年渡って そういう環境の中でお釈迦様が現れたんです
それでお釈迦様は では魂は青いですか
赤いですか？という 私は青いと赤いと混じった色やと思いますよと言っていいんですかね
それで平和的でいいですよ
そうすると 七つの色を背負ってますからね
それで黒い色もありますよ
とにかく色七つ魂にあって
それでお釈迦様が じゃあ平和的で
私は魂の色はこの七つも合わせたところの色やと言ったって何色ですかね
それは  [笑い]そういうもうガキみたいな考え方で
で ブッダとはもう喋りません
お釈迦様はすぐ気づいたこと
あら みんな魂について語ってるんですけど
魂自体が本当にあるかないかまず調べなくちゃあかんでしょうに
なんで魂っていう考え方が頭に浮かんだんでしょうかね
あなた方には あるならば
それが青いか赤いか それからの話でしょうと
だから前提崩すんですよ
いい加減みんな言ってることをペラペラペラペラ大昔するなよと
一人の人が何か赤いと言ったところで
別の人にそれはピンクだと言えるでしょうに
それが正しいか間違ってる
どちらでもないんですよ
ある人には赤く見える
だからしょうがないでしょうね
赤いんだけど ある人にはやっぱりこれはピンクだと思いますよとも言える
なぜならば 赤かピンクかっていうことは
この人の脳細胞の中で基準があるんだから
その基準で合わせて言ってるんですよ
だから派手な赤 赤色の基準が脳にある人が
これはピンクじゃないかなと言うかもしれません
なぜならば その人にとっては赤系
赤はもうちょっと薄く見えるんです
赤が薄いということは
別な色混じってるということなんです
だったらその人はピンクにする
しかし ある人の頭の中では
まあそれほど派手な赤ではなくて
簡単な色 薄い色をする人
いえ これは赤いでしょうと
ちょっと色が薄いだけですよと言うかもしれません
だからどちらも正しい
でも間違ってるという話じゃないんです
そういう場合は それは人の頭の中でそう考えるだけで
理屈の場合でも長いと言った途端
ある人はそれに短いと言うかもしれません
同じものに それ脳細胞に入り込んでる基準の問題なんですよ
人を見てあなたでっかいねと言ったところで
その人嘘言ってるわけじゃなくて
自分の頭の中にある人間の基準がありまして
それと合わせてみるとでかいんですよ
だからでかいと言うんです
でもまた他の人が見たら
あんたまあ普通でしょうと言うかもしれません
だからその人が普通ですか？あるいは体がでかい
どちらですかね だから世の中のこういう概念の争いっていうのは
決して結論がないんでしょうし
間違ってるんだ 正しいんだとか
そんなことを言うのはバカバカしい
ただ そのその人の頭の中に
脳細胞の中に入ってるまあ基準で言ってることで
それでその基準も勉強すればするほど変わるでしょうに
例えばアジアで南アジアで生活をずっと生活してる人の頭の中にある人間の基準というのは
その人々の体の体格に合わせてる標準基準でしょうに
その人は 10 年間ぐらいヨーロッパでアメリカで生活しちゃうと
でっかい体の人々ばっかり毎日見てるんだから
何のことなくあの基準が変わっちゃうんですよ
それで自分の国の人を見たら
あんた方すごい体が小さいですねと言うでしょうに
だからその脳細胞に入り込んじってる基準ももう変わるんですよ
勉強すればするほど だからどこまで変わるのかとか
どこまで勉強すればいいのかって
それも基準がないでしょうに
だから何でも中途半端で終わる世界なんです
我々の世界は 何にも結論ない世界
では 勉強すればするほど脳に入り込んでる基準が変わるならば
じゃあとことん変えて変えて変えていきましょうと
どこまで変えるんですかね
世界中の人間を見て 人間の基準を作った人が
もしかすると別なもう星から来ている
もうもう五 六メートルの体重の体格の生命を見たらどうなるんでしょうかね
だからクジラが大きいですかという質問答えられますかね
まあ今私の説明なかったならば平気で答えますよ
もう散々説明したんだから答えられないと言うんであって
そんなに鋭くはないと思います
だからこれクジラが大きいですかというような質問でしょうしね
どうやってそれ答えるんでしょうかね
では クジラたちの間で「お前は大きいすげ」という話がないでしょうに
普通ですからね [笑い]だからクジラっていうのは大きい動物でもなく
小さい動物でもなく普通です
で イワシは小さいんですかと
小さくないんですよ あれは普通です
で この魂の世界では まあまずこれが大きいか小さいかとかいうような話になって
それ自体もお釈迦様の論理的に見ると
もう何言ってるんでしょうかと
大きいも小さいも言えたもん
クジラが大きいか小さいか言えるんですかね
だからこのすごい宗教的思考あるんだけど
そういう そういうところで
この用事 用事のところで間違いがあるんですよ
私は何でそれ言って悪いでしょうかと
いくらみんなに嫌われても言う
私は そういう世間の宗教を信仰している人々の信仰を侮辱されたと思ったら
その場で立ち上がって反論してください
私も反論しているんだから
その権利はあります 隠れてこそこそと悪口言ったっても
自分が負けただけの話で
私は大胆に喋りますけど
この反論は受けませんということではないんです
いつでもオープンチャレンジで
物事っていうのはいつでもディスカッションで
ダイアログで 対話で成り立つんだから
私もすごい断言的に偏見的に喋ってるんだから
私はそれ知ってます 私は断言的で偏見的で
そんなことは喋ってはあかんと
でも そういう手段するしかもうしかない
だからいつでも対話にはオープンでいますから
まあ勇気のあるある方々はどうぞ
潰しますよ それは当たり前だから
でも潰せるかないかは別な話で
相手はものすごい手強 ifn だったら私も潰されるし
まあそういうこと とにかくこのお釈迦様の時代でね
魂が大きいか小さいか
永遠かそうでないかという
いろいろごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃたくさん宗教ありましたし
それで同じ宗教の中でも無数に宗派があるし
そういう考え方に分かれてしまって
で 互いに喧嘩するし ちょっとそんなちょっと常識で考えれば
クジラが大きいかと聞いても
何の意味もない では 初めてクジラを見た人間がびっくりしましたよと
あの大きさにと言えば
それは間違っていることじゃないんです
それはその人の経験だから
どうしようもないんです
それは あなたバカではないかと
クジラは大きくても小さくもないんだよと言ったっても
それは別なこと 話で 本人が初めてクジラ見たら
あの巨大さにびっくりする
それが その人の脳の中にある生命の大きさの基準
経験は小さい小さい動物をずっと見ていて
初めてその基準を覆す
もう到底つまらないものを見るとびっくりする
それでその基準も頭に入りますから ２
回目に見たらあれほどはびっくりしませんし
もしかすると今まで馬見てライオン見て驚いたのに
それから面白くなくなるかもしれません
なんだ こんな見るならばクジラ見た方がいいやと
いうふうに人の性格まで変わるかもしれませんし
そういうのはね そんなに大した問題ではなくて
その個人の考え方のことであって
正しいとも言えないし
間違っているとも言えないし
個人はそういうふうに経験するんだということで
そこで難しくなっちゃいますから
できるだけ話は元に戻りますが
そこで魂大きいかないかという話する前に
魂って何？という ある？その質問にまず答えなくちゃいけない
みんな前提でそれがあると思っていたので
その固定概念が問題だと
そこで世の中に固定概念いくつかあります
神 魂 不死 まだありますけど
私は宗教の世界を語ってますからね
宗教に関係ある固定概念
どうやって不死っていうのは概念作れますか？作れないはずなんです
経験的に クジラ見てびっくりしたっていうことは事実であって
それがちゃんとした具体的な話で
それは何とか処理できます
びっくりするなよと このバカとクジラ
あれ普通やと言えば そうかは自分が経験がなくてまずかったというぐらいのことで
それで終わるんですよ
でも 不死という概念どう作ったかと
永遠という概念どう作ったかと
魂 神という概念どう作ったかと
そこら辺の研究はしていないんですね
誰一人も そこで前提としてあるということにして
それが何かとそれから考える
それ全て妄想になるんです
経験ないものについて語ってるんだから
経験しているならばいいんですよ
例えばある人がこう言うならば
何か私は何か魂があるような感じがしますよというならば
話は通じます それ本人の経験だから
それはどういう経験でしょうかと
その場合は話は成り立ちます
具体的に  それもなくて
もう魂はなんせとかね
神様はいる だから神様はいるという人々がいて
いないという人々 どちらでもいい加減ですよ
それで喧嘩する 殺し合いまでやる
神様はいると人々は この神様はどういうものかと
名前を付けちゃうんです
一人がアッラーと名前をつけるは
一人はジェホワという名前をつけるは
一人はアフラ・マズダという名前をつけるは
一人はブラフマという名前を付けて
これで殺し合いやるんです
神様はブラフマであってアフラ・マズダではないんだと
偉大なる神様はジェホワであってもアッラー・ターハラーではありませんと
でやり合っちゃうんです
そこはもうあの桜の花は白い色ですか
ピンク色ですかという喧嘩と同じなんですよ
日本の方々は薄ピンク色やと言うかもしれませんだけど
私は論理的にはほぼ白いだからなんで白色にしないのかと
ピンクあることは認めます
でも割合はね 考えたこともないでしょうね
白には混じったら白じゃないんです
白に  白に色が混じったら
もうそれは白ではないんです
少しでも  それだったらもう完全に混じって欲しいでしょうね
一部でしょ？まあそんなのはどうでもいい話で
だから私はもう冗談喧嘩になる課題出してみたんですね
で 皆様はピンクという態度を取ると
私はいえ 白という態度をとってみる
私の話も成り立ちますよ
私は反論 「本当にピンクですか？」と我々は 「
完璧に」と言えば「んー」と言うでしょうね 「
それでも割り当ててみてください」と 「
白い色とピンク色はどんな
どれぐらい どれぐらいでしょうか」と
なんで八十パーセント以上八十五パーセントぐらいの白いは無視して
十五パーセントのピンクだけ派手にする
何か意味がありますか？それにはと
何か重大な意味というのは何かありますかと
で 私は言いますよ 周りは白いんだからピンクは派手にコントラストで見えてるだけでしょうと
目で だから仕事しているのは白色ではないかと
あの腰抜けのピンク色を引き立ててあげるために
いくらでもそういう理屈成り立つでしょうに
でもくだらんでしょう
結局は 結局はくだらん
勝手にすればいいっていう話で
ピンクにしたければどうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
白色にするんだったら勝手にやってくださいと
それだけの話で 別にもうどうったことはない
だから概念知識に対して仏教の立場はそういう立場なんです
あまりもしつこく言うと反論出すんですけど
気にしない だからといって
あまりもしつこく桜はピンクやと言っちゃうと
もう片っ端から潰しますけど
もうくだらないってこと知ってます
そういうふうにも別に喧嘩する必要はないんだと
それに殺し合いやる必要はないんだと
ただの頭の概念でしょうと
そういうことで この神様は何者か
名前は何なのかとかね
その神様はどんなやり方でお礼を礼をすればよろしいかとか
あるだけのもう話あります
それはもう私から見れば
桜はピンクか白いかってどちらに決めるのかというぐらいの話ですよ
一日五回お祈りするべきか
あるいは日曜日だけで十分でしょうかとかね
だから妄想概念に引っかかってる人々にとっては
それは大変な世界で そう簡単ではないんですよ
もう 批判したってももう危ないし殺されるし
それぐらい概念にはしがみついている
だからブッダは自由を語ったっていうことは
そういう思考の自由も語ってるんです
素晴らしく そこで魂などの話になってくると
お釈迦様は前提として認めるなよと
何で？客観的な具体的なデータからいきましょうと
魂があるかないかという疑問が私の脳細胞に浮かんだのは
ここで私が生きているんだという実感があるんだからでしょうと
まず これ実感の中で生まれた反応でしょうし
だったらそれは何なのかと
この生きているという実感というのは何なのかと
これ具体的だからね これは明確に分析して把握して理解しておきましょうと
それで具体的に把握できること
具体的に研究できることのみを研究していく
客観的に 間違ってでも微妙にでも固定概念は導入しない
それはすっごく危険 危険なんです
それで全部思考は脱線するんです
これヨーロッパの哲学でよく見えますよ
みんな立派なもう頭が素晴らしいんですよ
もう並の知識人たちじゃないんです
だから自由に考えようと思うんだけど
自分の頭の中で文化的にいくつかの固定概念がもう入り込んでいるんです
それがわからないんです
気づけてないんです だから
あの哲学はズルズルズルズルずっとねじ曲がっていくんです
ねじ曲がったことで役に立たない
ただの分厚い本を書いただけで
誰かいますかね 西洋哲学思考で心安らかになって幸福を感じた人が
哲学を勉強したことで
私は随分もう機嫌よく幸福できてるんだよと
一人でも まあ将棋をやって楽しむような感じなんですね
だから それはどういうことかって
別にそういう方々は頭が悪かったわけじゃないんですよ
信じられないほど脳細胞が動いたんですけど
微妙にでも固定概念があると
思考がそこら辺に傾いていくんです
すっごくこの固定概念というのはタチが悪くて手強いんですよ
だから神という固定概念があると
自分が実際自分の存在を実存主義的に分解して分解していくんです
初めはちゃんと具体的にいくんですよ
それでバラバラバラバラ分解していって
いったところでもう自分にも力のもう尽くすところありますから
もうもう疲れたというところになってくると
あの固定概念にぴったしつけて終わるんです
だからこれはお釈迦様から見ればもう一つネタが出ましたと笑うためにという
新ネタがあるぞということぐらいの話です
それでブッダの特色って言えば
それこの微妙にでも固定概念を導入しない
ということで それでもし客観的な研究結果として証明されたら
正直に認める これが魂ですと
でもそういうものは見つからなかったし
お釈迦様が人間なんで苦しみのかっていう課題でしたから
その原因の一つになっちゃったんです
魂は その固定概念も人間の巨大な苦しみの原因であると
この妄想概念が それで執着が生まれてきて
ものすごく苦しむんだよと
穏やかな気持ち 自由な気持ちになれないんだと
足が引っ張られてるんだと
ということで お釈迦様は完全たる自由を経験して
それをもうみんなに教えている
そういうことで この 哲学は作る自由は誰にでもありますけど
この何か前提としてあって
それから語るっていうことはそんなに大したことじゃないんです
桜はピンクでも白いでも別に大したことはない話で
断言できません どちらにでも
ただ時間の無駄 うるさい話で終わっちゃうんです
そういう争論で そこでまた唯識論に戻ります
唯識理論の場合でも もう心
初めは心ありきという前提があって
心のみありきと それから説明するんだから
もう そんなにね 大したことはないということは残念ながら言わざるを得ないんです
それでまああの そういう前提があって語ると
哲学っていうのは自分で矛盾を持つんですよ
あるいはテーシス アンチテーシス
いつでも一緒セットっていうのはそういうわけで
論と反論はね で それはどこかでこの固定概念あって語るんだから
これでまたややこしいのは
何か前提的な概念がないと語れないんですよ 「
このご飯はおいしいですよ」というために
何か固定概念がないと言えないんですね 「
あの人は綺麗な人ですよ」というためにはね
何か固定概念が必要なんです
ここ難しいんですよ だから今までずっと私が喋ったものの
いろいろ固定概念があって喋るんだから
もう反論はいわゆるアンチテーシスはいつでも付いてるんです
ブッダの哲学っていうのはそういう風な世界で
あの だから あの だからお釈迦様はチャレンジするんです 「
私が言っている言葉は
もし反対できればやってみてください」と
この言葉の使い方っていうのは
ブッダ以外そう簡単にできんということですよ
言っているのは それは言ってないんです
その代わりに 「まあ語るところは完全にして語ってますよ」と 「
完全にして」と言ったところで
すごい大胆な言葉なんです
これは違うということは言えない
だからものすごくこの
大した教えですよ すごい大変な教えなんです
それ簡単に理解できるんだとかね
思っても その智慧の壮大さっていうのは
もう昔 まあ考えきれないほど
言葉では語れないんです
言葉っていうのは 一応前提があって
固定概念があって成り立つんでしょうし
そういう不完全な言葉で完全な真理を語っているという
それで有識という世界の中でも
この まず彼らがこの不可視
不可視というか 知り得ない
意識化することはまるっきりできない「阿頼耶識」という概念を作るんです
その時点でそれが否定されているんです
絶対意識不可能だったら
あんた知らないでしょ？[笑い] なんで知らないことをごちゃごちゃ喋るんですかね
だから信仰でしょうと
それが だったら神様を信じて立派な本を書く人と同じです
[終始背景音楽]で いくつかまあ
で 矛盾がある まあ仏教の人々だから
もうこれすごくずる賢いんですよ
分かってるんです 矛盾があるっていうことは
唯識を語れた人々も バカじゃないんだからとにかく
それで逃げるんです これは天国でミルク菩薩
菩薩様が語ったものを我々人間に言うだけだからね
いちいち文句言うなよと
それでお手上げ  でもそれ菩薩が語ったっていうことは
ブッダじゃないから完全だとは言えんで
そこで白状しているようなものじゃないですか
それはだから菩薩にしてるんです
まあ少々いろいろあってもね
まあ真面目に勉強しなさいよと
で 彼らが言うべきだったのは
この輪廻の説明ね 仏教は無我論だから
俗世間には無我であって輪廻って成り立たないんだよと思ってるでしょうね
仏教の世界では無我だから輪廻成り立つんですよ
無常だから成り立つんです
無常だからずっと終わりなく回転するでしょうに
だから仏教の人々には当たり前なんです
自我持ってきた途端 全部道徳も何だかんだ死んでしまっちゃうんですね
自我が永遠不滅だから
人殺したってもアートマンが変わりませんだからね
だからそこら辺で それでもアートマン信じてる人々は
あなた方は非アートマン語って
もうもう偉そうに輪廻転生のこと言うなよと
アートマンがあるならば
人が死んだら魂が別なところに引っ越しするっていう話はわかりやすいではないかと
そんなこの子供の話じゃないんだよっていうところで説明しようとしているんです
それでこのいろいろな中間論もね
唯識論もいろいろ出てきたんです
で 中間論はこのあまりにも論理ばっかしで言っちゃって
道徳は忘れてしまっちゃって
修行の意味もなくなっちゃって
非仏教の教えになってしまったんです
それがまずいんだから
唯識論はやっぱり色ぐらいは認めましょうというふうなお互いに補い合ったりするんですよ
でもどう語っても完全には語れないんですよ
だから このテーラワーダの世界はブッダの話は崩すなよと
崩しちゃうとひどい目にあいますと
そこは放っておきましょうということで
テーラワーダの人々は保守派だとすごく非難されてるんです
新しく物事考えないんだと
向こう側から非難される
でも まあテーラワーダはそういう立場を取っちゃったんですね
経典は変えませんと 新しい哲学は作りませんと
まあでもみんな仲良く同じお寺にいたんだからインドでね
日本で思うほど宗派喧嘩はなかったんです
それはもうすごい品のある知識的な
あなたそう言っても私はこう思いますよっていうぐらいの話で
一緒にご飯食べてるんです
同じ部屋に寝るんです
これまああとずいぶん後ですね
まあ中国 日本なんか来てからいろいろ分かれたんであって
今でも台湾とかね 大乗系の寺では別にみんな仲良くもう
やってますよ 仲良くいるんですけど
考え方はそれぞれ違うんですよ
そこは強調する それは強調しながら
すごく仲良くする だからこの仏教の世界でも
まああのシーア派とスンニ派とみたいな殺し合いとかそんなのはありえないんです
それは決してありえない
いくら宗派が全く違うものであろうとも
一緒に托鉢にして お互いに分け合って
あんたこれ好きでしょうとか
その人にあげて 私はこれちょうだいとかね
そうやってもう分け合ってご飯を食べたりをするんですけど
話になるともう結構違いますよということで
ぐらいで まあ結構まあ雰囲気は良かったんですけど
でも仏教潰れちゃったんですね
インドで 消えましたけど
まあそれはなぜそこまで話を脱線させたかというと
この心って何なのかという説明はないということを言いたかっただけ
だから心の説明は必ずしなくちゃいけない
責任かかってる唯識の世界でも説明できていない
それは前提として扱うんです
それで誰でも犯す間違いは犯している
誰でも でお釈迦様は心って何なのかという定義ははっきりありますし
で こちらでは心の特色であって
こちらでもね 別なところでもいっぱい全部心について語ってますから
で 心はどういうものかと
まず仏教で強調するのは
もしかすると ブッダが我々魂
アートマンと言っていることはもう嫌で
それに心という単語を入れているだけではないかと
我々も何かなぞける場合は
人がつけて同じものでも同じ名前をつけないでしょうに
同じ名前をつけちゃうとちょっと困ったりする
例えばこちらテーラワーダ協会だからミャンマーのテーラワーダ協会もありますね
これ名前あまりにも同じ
どうしようかと で 何か名前だけでやってるのみんな同じ
ミャンマーの方々も同じテーラワーダ仏教やってますけど
で 同じテーラワーダブディストアソシエーションにしちゃうと
こちらもテーラワーダブディストアソシエーションでこれこんがらがっちゃうんです
別に何の差もない ただ向こうはミャンマー人の集まり
それだけの話で こちらは日本人だけの集まりで
やってるのは同じ仏教で
だから名前はどうしても同じくなるんです
それでこちらはジャパンテーラワーダブディストアソシエーションにして
向こうは単なるテーラワーダブディストアソシエーションにしてＪが入ってるんです
こちらには これでなんとか
だからそれぐらいの単純な話ではないかと
アートマンと言っていることに
ブッダがマナチッタという言葉を使っているだけではないかという風に反論できそう
あるお坊さんがそう思ったんですよ
サーティってお坊さんなんですけど
中部経典にある経典でこのタデーイダンヴィンヤーナサンターヴィサンサレテアナンニャンという考え方を出しちゃったんです
いわゆる輪廻転生するのはヴィンヤーナです
色ですよと 変わらない
この今私の色がどんどんどんどん流転して輪廻転生するんだよと
色以外別に何もないんだと
色 いわゆるアナンニャンというのは
それ哲学的な概念で同一ものであると
転生しても同一ものであると
この同一という言葉にお釈迦様は随分反論する
反発する 同一という言葉に
アイデンティティという言葉に
まあこんなほんと本格的に仏教語取るとみんな逃げるからやめましょうか
本格的なブッダの世界はちょっときつい
アイデンティティという言葉がありまして
[笑い]ものすごい仏教はそれには反対する
同一性 で 同一ですよとインドは言っていたんです
仏教は同一ではありません
しかし 異質でもありませんと
それで同一 全く別々という二つがあって
仏教はどちらでも否定する
で わからなくなります
そうすると だからこれは因縁という法則だよと
これはもう人間にはそう簡単に理解できないんだと
しかし 世の中で常にありますよと
一対一であるのは因縁のみですと
という仏説は因縁論になるんです
因縁の場合は同一とも言えないし
同一ではないとも言わないんですよ
花が原因で実が結果でしょ
同一ですかね では別々
まるっきり関係なくとは言えないでしょうに
花が枯れて それで受粉して
それからどんどんじわじわじわじわと実がなってくる
でも一般常識としては
この花からこの実が出たんだよと言っても間違いはありません
でもどう見たっても この花と果物っていうのはすごい違いますよと言いたければどうぞと
違うんだから でもあんまりもしつこく言わない
言うなよと 花と実がまるっきり関係ない別々のものだと言っちゃうと
花がなくても実がなりますよと
それはないんだから 例えば花と電信柱はまるっきり別々のものでしょうに
電信柱があってもなくても
そちらは実がなるでしょうに
そういうことで まあ一般的に言うならば別にいいんだけど
あまりしつこく言うなよと
という風な この因果論というのは成り立つんです
成り立つんじゃなくて
因果論は事実ですからね
それであるお坊さんがこのヴィンヤーナ
心が同一であると わかったわかった
お釈迦様おっしゃっていることは
無我 もう魂がありませんよというのはわかりました
しかし お釈迦様おっしゃっているのはこの心のことでしょう
だから 心がそうやって流転していくんだと
言うと お坊さんたちがあなた言っていることは全く違うんだよと
これはまるっきりお釈迦様を侮辱しているんだと
ブッダを馬鹿にしてるんだと
あんたは ただ そのお坊さんにわからないんですよ
なんでそんなことを言うのかと
私はお釈迦様がこういうふうに教えているんではないかなと理解しているんだから
別に侮辱する 馬鹿にする気持ちは全くないんだよということで
全然めげない それでもう阿羅漢たちはこの人を
お釈迦様を馬鹿にしているんだということを知っているんです
この人は知らない それで行ったんです
お釈迦様のところ お釈迦様の反応が 「
お前 なんで私を侮辱しているんですか」と
いきなり 何を知って私を侮辱しているんですかと
それでお釈迦様 あのお坊様
初めてびっくりしたんですね
自分が知らないうちにお釈迦様を侮辱しているんだと
ってお釈迦様もあまりにも浅はかしい考え方だからね
お前勝手にしなさいよと
私は比丘たちに真理語りますよと言っても
もう無視して比丘たちにこの
また説法したんです そこまでもう
いわゆる対話にとって
もう質問を聞いたり 答え出したりすることさえもしなかったんです
それぐらいその比丘をもう無視しちゃったんです
普通だったら異論を持ってくると
お釈迦様は随分優しく異論を受け取って
もう質問して 相手に質問させて
で 答えて答えて 相手から答えもらって
ちゃんと説明して納得させるんです
あんたは勝手に自分の考え方で旗を立てて
勝手にやってくださいと
私には関係ない 私はここで私は比丘たちに語りますということで
経典がずっと続けているので
それぐらいお釈迦様は厳しいんですよ
同一という言葉を使っちゃうと
そこで他宗教でアートマンという霊魂という
仏教では心という だから仲良くしなさいというのはできないんですよ
[背景音楽]仲良くしますけど
喧嘩はしませんけど そういう心理のところでは違うということははっきりと強調した上で仲良くする
我々犬とも仲良くするでしょうに
だからって犬って人間であるという
それはちょっとやめてほしいんですよ
うちの犬にも選挙権は必要やと
投票する権利は必要やとかね
言ったら向こうはダメだ
なんてダメと言うんです
私は私の子供だと思っているんだからとかね
そこまでは言ってほしくないんです
自分飼ってる犬は子供やと思ってのは
それは勝手でいいんだけど
それ以上は言ってほしくないでしょ
だからこの違うところははっきり違うというところを知った上で仲良くする
それ本物の仲良くなんです
ごまかしじゃないんだから
で だからお釈迦様は心の説明になってくるってなってくるとパンダナ
これ揺れるんだと 安定していない
揺れるものっていうのはもう確立できるものじゃないでしょうに
やっと成り立ってシャボン玉のようなものになる
シャボン玉っていうのはいつでも揺れてるでしょうに
ちょっとしたことではじけちゃうでしょうに
だからすぐすぐすぐすぐ変わる
ほとんどシャボン玉と同じなんです
それでチャパラン あてにもならない
だったら守るべきなのに守り難い
それから正しいやるべきことはやらす
やらすことはできない
不可能 ということだから
これ魂と違うでしょ 何のこと
他宗教でおっしゃっている霊魂とは随分違うんです
違うんですけど まあ他宗教は霊魂と言っているのは心なんです
で 霊魂でいたってもどうったことない
ものすごくくだらないものなんです
魂は だから魂で理解できる方々は
魂っていうのはあんまりにもくだらない
あてにならない いい加減なものであるというふうに理解するしかないんです
尊いとかなんとかとかいうところじゃないんだと
それがすごい具体的な話ですよ
なぜならば 皆様は知ってるでしょ
嘘をついてはいけないと
嫉妬してはいけないと知ってるでしょう
怒りに狂ってはいけないと
これはとんでもない 情けないんだと
タチが悪いんだと知ってるでしょうに
夫婦喧嘩なんかものすごい気持ち悪いと知ってるでしょうに
知らない？知ってるのに何でやってるんですかね
夫婦喧嘩してはいけない
あれは気持ち悪いと 知ってるんだったらやらなきゃいいでしょうに
でもやってるでしょうに
嘘をついてはいけないと知ってるでしょうに
しかし嘘しか何か言う？嘘以外？で
この間誰か得体知れないメールがあって
そちらにある文章あったんです
で Ambassador
is an honest person appointed for to lie for his country. という定義なんです
大使というのは自分の国のために嘘をつく
自分の国のために嘘をつくために委任している正直な人間であると
という定義なんです 面白かったんですけど Ambassador
is a person who is appointed to lie for his country an
honest person. で honest
というところ 正直な人間っていうところはすごい面白かった
だからこの私たちは嘘をついてはいけないと知ってるんですけど
結局嘘しか別に喋ることは何もないんです
嫉妬してはいけないと知ってるんだけど
嫉妬するんです 夫婦喧嘩は良くない
気持ち悪いと知ってるんだけど
もう一番簡単にやるのは夫婦喧嘩でしょうね
こんなちょっとのことでもいいんですね
ものすごい喧嘩する こんなちょっとのこと
例えば旦那さんに子供を公園に連れて行ってくださいと
本人がものすごい何か大事な仕事があって
ちょっと今忙しいんだ
それだけでももうものすごくもう爆弾交換しますよ
じわじわと すぐあんたいつもそうですということを言っちゃうでしょうね
何か言ったら で 向こう怒るんですね
なんでいつもそうですって言うんです
今はちょっともう大変
大変忙しいんだから言っただけの話ではないかと
だからまあそれで喧嘩するんですけど
それからえらく二人とも気持ちが悪くて
せっかくの休みなのに一日ももう嫌な気持ちでいて
だから そういう風に具体的に見てみると
我々にはやっぱり知ってはいるんだけど
やめることはできない状態でしょ
だからドゥンニワーラヤンというのはそういう意味なんです
ワーレーティっていうのはストップさせること
やめさせることなんです
これが無理だ できないと
ドゥラッカンというのは守りがたいということなんですね
で 心に余計な考え方 余計な思考
余計なもの入っちゃうと
心がものすごくもう混乱してしまって
罪まで起こす起こす可能性あります
あ 気をつけなくちゃ 気をつけなくちゃと思ってるでしょうに
でもこれできないんですよ
例えば誰かが喧嘩している
自分が喧嘩は良くない
怒ってはいけない とは知ってるんだけど
この二人も自分も知ってるし
で スイスイいろいろやっぱりもうなんとか割り込んで
なんとかこれ喧嘩やめさせなくちゃいけないし
それで何か言ったところで
自分もカッと怒る可能性もあります
曲がりませんよ いくら落ち着いて
だからテレビで犯罪誰かが起こした途端
決まってるスクリプト持っていってインタビューするでしょ
その人の顔を見てないそこら辺に住んでる人々が
その人どういう人間 とっても立派な方でしたと
みんな言う 質問も決まってて
答えも決まってるんでしょうけど
私だったらあんた見たことがあるのかと聞きますけどね
で 本当は顔も覚えてないかもしれませんですけどね
その事件が起きたということもテレビで聞くんであって
隣に起きるということでも
大体日本の警察っていうのはあんまりばらまいたりしないし
情報は だからきちんとそこら辺はもうもう何て言いますか
クローズされちゃって
もうそのまま持っていくんであって知らない
だから私は留学生活にいた時は
ある人が自殺したんです
一緒にいる私たち誰も知らなかったんだから
女性でしたからセクションは別でしたけど
で それでも知らない なんか車十台十五台ぐらいさーっと来ていて
それももうどんな車かも訳も分からない
別に警察とか何とも書いてもなかったし
なんで今日はすごいたくさん車あるのかって
すぐささっと出て行っちゃったんです
それでもうなんとなくちらちらと噂として何々さんが自殺しちゃったんだと
ずいぶん後で それからテレビからあげて
あんたあの人どういう
そんなもんなんです だからまあ
その時よくみんな言うのはとてもいい人でしたと
子供はすごく可愛がっていたんだ
子供を殺してるんですよ
あの人は子供すごい可愛がってたんですけど
分かりませんね なんででしょうと
分かるわけないでしょうね
だからそこはすごい まあ茶番劇でもヤラセでも面白くないんだけど
やっぱり面白くないと言ったっても
そちらに心の真理はあるんですよ
本当にわからないんですよ
もう私の子供は大好きやとかね
言ってるんですけど それ殺しちゃうということもあり得るんです
だからずいぶん守りにくい
それでブッダの立場だからといってね
腰を上げて あ しょうがないと
そんな情けないことを言うなよと
これは難しいってことは
心っていうのはもう揺らぐは
もう当てにならないわ
もう守りにくいわ コントロールしにくいわ
それが心というものであると
それで言いながら これは魂の動機ではありませんとということもあるんです
それで何するのかで だからしっかりと育てなさいよと心を
それこそ知恵のある人がやることやと
ウジュンカロとメーダイ
知恵のある人はこれはまっすぐ伸ばすという
しっかり育てていくんだと
そういうことだから 頑張るしかないんです
私にずっと弱み言ったっても
やっぱり妄想が出るんですから
もうしょうがないでしょうとかね
そんなこと言ったっても
自分が自分の癖でいつでも怒ったりするんだから
それはそういう話は仏教には成り立たない
もう最初からもう言ってるんだから
ですからこの本当にもうもう言い訳は成り立たないように語っているんです
言い訳成り立たない 心はしっかり育てなくちゃいけない
それでウスカーローはテージャナ
たとえ話 で ウスカーローテージャナっていうのは簡単ですね
あれは弓師が矢を作るようにという意味なんですね
だから皆様に経験のない例えで申し訳ないんですけど
昔のね 弓矢っていうのは木の枝で作るでしょ
あの鉄とかね そんなものはアルミとかあったわけじゃないし
鉄はありましたけど 戦争するために戦うために矢を作る
全部鉄で作っちゃうと戦争になりません
だから重くて これでも何千何万本も作らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからいくらでも木の枝ありますから
その木の枝で作るんですよ
でも木の枝っていうのはあれで矢を作れますかね
木の枝っていうのはぐにゃぐにゃでしょうに
この世の中でまっすぐ伸びる枝っていうのは 1本も存在しないんです
ぴったしまっすぐという
1本も存在しない ぐにゃぐにゃです
たとえまっすぐな竹みたいなね
まっすぐに伸びそう伸びてるようなものでもまっすぐじゃないんです
だからもう諦める 矢を作ること
この枝は曲がってる これも曲がってる
あれも曲がってる これ矢になりませんよとかね
それで弓師はあの枝を叩いたり温めたり縛ったり
水の中にもう何ヶ月かもつけておいたり
いろんな工程を経て ぴったしまっすぐの矢を作るんです
大体もう言えば おそらくまずこの自然で生で生でしょ
枝っていうのはそれ生は役に立たない
曲がりますから だからまず干す
干したら硬い枝になる
それは適当に切る 切ってから泥とか水とか中に入れておくんです
1ヶ月とかぐらい それでまた柔らかくなる
その柔らかさっていうのは別の柔らかさ
前と同じじゃないんです
そこでしっかりと伸ばしておく
で 伸ばしてきっちりと縛っておいて
そのまま自然に干すようにする
それでも危ないんです
放っておいちゃうとまた曲がる可能性あります
それから温めるんです
それ 温めてはまた伸ばして
また伸ばして そういういろいろ工程があって
それで出来上がったというと
それはそのままもうもう二度と曲がりません
だから弓師は枝が曲がってるんだということで諦めませんよ
枝が曲がってるんだということは当たり前
だから心もだらしない
コントロールできない
清らかになれない 悪ばっかりやる
心というのは悪いことしかやらない
だからといって諦めないということが仏教のところなんです
また同じみ スギノゲーでも言ってます
ワージョーワタレキットオーカモーカテウッバトーパリパンデティダンチッタンマーラデイヤンパハタデーでワージョーっていうのは魚ですね
タレキットタレっていうのは陸上
キットっていうのは捨てられたということ
陸上に捨てられた魚のように
陸上に魚を捨てられたらどうなるんですかね
倒れます  すごく動き回りますね
落ち着かないんです 怯えているんです
もう死ぬんだから 呼吸できないんだから
だからすごく飛び上がったり
もう怯えたりする 心っていうのは常にその状態にあるんだよと
オーカモーカとウッバトっていうのは
オーカンモーカっていうのはこちらあちらこちらと飛び回る
だから魚ももうかなり力絞って飛び上がったりする
で また落ちたらまだ飛び上がったりする
どれほど怖くなるでしょうかね
もう飛び上がるのも力が必要ですけども
呼吸もしてない かなり苦しいでしょう
我々の心はずっと 20時間それぐらい怯えていますよ
本当かと思うかもしれませんだけど
それはもうずっと同じ状態だからわからないだけ
本当に心というのはいつでも不安で怯えて
かなり喫水状態なんです
パリパンデティダンチッタン
パリパンデティっていうのは揺れる
イダンチッタン この心が
その心もこのように揺れるんだと
それでマーラディヤンパハテヴェ
マーラの悪魔の領域を捨てなさいよと
捨てるべきであると 悪魔の領域って何なのかって
これは文学的になりすぎてしまいますけど
魚の例えば魚は陸上に捨てられると
陸上は魚にとって幸せなところじゃないでしょうに
大変危険なところでしょうに
そちらにいるべきではありません
そこで我々人間 生命としてマーラの世界っていうのは
陸上って何なのかというと輪廻のことなんですね
いわゆるマーラっていうのは大したこと難しくはないんです
理解するならば この目耳鼻に頼って刺激を受けて
ああ生きていてよかった
聞いてよかったというこの生き方がマーラの領域なんです
私たちの心は耳から入る情報で
目から入る情報で 鼻から入る情報で
舌から体から入る情報で回転しているんです
だから この世間からはなかなか離れにくいんです
その情報で頭の中でずっと妄想するんです
だから頭で考えるものはすべて眼耳鼻舌身の情報であって
それ以外何もないんです
そこで眼に目でものを見ても
本当は見てないんです
目で情報が入ると頭の中で幻覚を起こすんですよ
現象が頭を作るんですね
見たっていうのはその現象のことなんです
本当に目に触れた情報何なのか知らない
耳に触れる情報は音なんですけど
でも我々はそれを音で認識するんじゃなくて
車だ 救急車だ 音楽だとするんです
それは頭の中で合成する現象なんです
それで私は世の中のことを考えていると
あの現象を並び替えているだけで
だから見て花が綺麗というよりも
とんでもない嘘の世界なんです
[背景音楽]見てあ 綺麗でしたというぐらいだったらね
それでも現象ですけど
まあそれほどもう罪が重いわけじゃないんです
それでじっとこうやってね
もう首を曲げて考えるでしょうね
あれはすべて眼耳鼻舌身から入った情報を現象化したところで
現象を並び替えているんです
だからもう思考妄想というのは全く真実から離れるんです
本当にみんなもう事実からものすごいかけ離れた世界に行くでしょ
考えると その生き方 人間の生き方はマーラの領域ですね
マーラの国家ですね でもその国民はみんな痛い目に遭わせるんです
だからその国から早くも脱出しなくちゃいけないと
ということは解脱しなくちゃいけないということで
そこで心の話になってくると
このオーカモーカとウッベトという二行目の言葉がありますね
魚の場合はオーカーアノーカンということなんですけど
で えーと 何でしたっけ？あちらからこちら
こちらからあちらというふうに魚は飛ぶでしょう
でも心になってくるとその意味じゃないんです
今世で 今ここで生まれていて
心はずっと回転していますね
眼耳鼻舌身の情報で そこで死んだらいい加減やめればいいのに
また別なところに飛ぶんです
心が 落ち着きがないんだから
別なところに飛んで また眼耳鼻舌身を作って
また同じ回転をするんです
そこでオーカーアノーカンというのは
この世をあの世って意味なんです
この世から死んであの世に飛び出す
飛んだらあの世 またこの世になるでしょ
で そこからまたどこかへ飛ぶ
そこも終わりがなく 心はそうやって苦しんでいるんだと
輪廻転生の話なんです
輪廻転生をやめた方がよろしいと
で これぐらいものすごい難しいことを
本当はただ日本語訳読んだらね
なんで単純な話ではないかと思いますけど
あのブッダの話は単純ではなくて
結構難しい話です かなり勉強しないと
でも事実ですよ 妄想ではありません
これが事実なんです 嘘だと思うならば言ってみてください
心は揺れるものではありません
安定しているんだよと言いたければ
どうぞ言ってみてください
当たりになりますよと
自分の心はと 私なんかはしっかり約束なんか守りますよと
自信があれば言ってみてください
それはあり得ません だから我々約束を守ることがいいことだと思っている
なんであれいいことですかね
守れないんだからでしょうね
嘘をつかないのはいいことだと思って
なぜかというと嘘をつくんだからでしょうね
なんで呼吸するのはいいことだと言わないんですかね
人間はみんなもう生まれた時から死ぬまで呼吸していて
本当に立派ですよと めげずに頑張ってるんだと
なんで言わないんですかね
誰もやめないでしょ？呼吸することは
だからやってるんだから
別にそれは美徳でもないし
道徳でもない ただそれだけの話
誰でも人類が約束を守るんだったら
呼吸するような感じで
美徳でも道徳でも何でもないんです
だから私なんかしっかり約束を守るぞという場合は
やっぱり本当は嘘言ってるし
まあ実行できないし でもそれは当たり前
道徳なんですよ 私は嘘をつかないと言ったら
それは当たり前 道徳的なことを言ってます
つかないと言ったら嘘なんですけど
私は嘘をつかないように頑張ると言った方が言語学的に正しいんです
だから仏教は言葉使うと
私はこれから嘘をつきませんよということではなくて
私はこれから嘘をつかないということに精進しますと
そういう風に言葉でも約束でも
すごくあの完成に近いところで使うんです
人間というのは そういう言い方はもうごちゃごちゃでもういいや
うるさいと思っちゃいますから
もう随分断言的に喋れます
まあそういうことで とにかく我々は一応正直に約束は守りたいんですが
しかしその条件によって
これは分かりません 人と会う約束していても
途中で何か起きちゃうと
もうそれでもうできなくなるんでしょう
そういうわけで この 心はすぐすぐ変わる
変わらないというふうなことを言えるならば
まあチャレンジしてやっても構いません
私の気持ちなんかは変わりませんと
そういう人々はいますよ
それはどういう気持ちかというと
怒り 憎しみ 例えば人のことを怒って
もう嫌だ あの人とは別れますよと
そこで周りの人はあのあの人と別れたらあんた大変でしょうと
もうやり直してくださいと
機嫌直してくださいと
仲直りしてくださいと
絶対私なんかは決めたら決めたぞと偉そうなことを言うんです
あれは怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬
欲の場合なんですよ みんな偉い性格がいいんですね
その時は 信頼もできる
その場合 あの人はあの人のことを憎しんでる
それはもう折り紙付きやと
なんでそっちを気持ち変わる人はその時だけ変わらないんですか？というと
心は悪しか起こせませんだから
心は知っているのは怒ること
欲張ること 無知になることしか知らないんですね
それやっているだけできること
絶対変わりませんと言ったっても
ちょっと条件変えちゃうと変えるんですよ
何のことなく 例えばあの人と絶対仲直りしませんと言ったところで
あんた知らないだけで
あの人は本当はこの  5億円ぐらい価値がある
すごい土地持っているんだよと
それをあなたに言ってないんだと
なぜかというと あんたびっくりさせようと思って
あなたの名義にしようと思って
こうもう反抗せないですよ
あなたはもう それ言ったら
あ そうですかと言ってこそこそまた仲直りするんです
それだから欲なんか出しちゃうと
あの怒りが消えていくんです
だってすごく喧嘩して
もう二度とあなたとは一緒にはいませんよと言って
まあ怒っていると まあ他人第三者に言うでしょうね
あ そうかなるほどわかった
あの人言ったこと何やと
あなたのことと なんかあの人すごくあんたすごく可愛くて親切ないい人だなとすごく悩んでいたんだよと
あんたみたいな人っていうのは
もう 100万人にも一人いないんだぞと
珍しい人間だと褒めていたんだよと
だからあんた喧嘩したんだ
だからと言った途端気持ち変わるんですよ
あ 私のことそんなに褒めてるんでしょうかと
すぐ行って仲直りする
あ この間ごめんと 人間っていうのはそんなもんなんですよ
だから欲 怒り 無知の間だったらいくらでも回転させる
怒るんじゃなくて その人のことを心配しなさいよ
慈悲を持ちなさいと言ったら
これはもう頭の中にない言語なんです
ですから 心っていうのは次から次へとそういうふうに変わるんですし
私たちは変わらないと時々言うんだけど
それもどうったことない
いかに憎しみだったら変わらないだけ
それで心というのはそんなにありがたいものだと仏教で見てないんです
このエピソードがあって
あるお坊さんがこの名義八っていうお坊さんなんですけど
このすごい立派なお坊さんで
瞑想しようと思って このと
ある森に行ったんです
森って言ったってもこのマンゴー林なんですね
で 野生的自然な森ではないんです
マンゴーを植えている林で
だからマンゴーっていうのは大きな木でね
結構間ありますからね
結構マンゴー林っていうのはすごい気分がいいところなんです
そこであのマンゴーはものすごい空気清浄する機能を持ってます
殺菌作用を持ってるんです
マンゴーの葉っぱなんかには
で ちょっと葉っぱちょっと潰してどこかに置いておくと
この空気の中の細菌までなくなるんです
で そういういろいろ機能あるんです
そこで何か香りでない何か匂いがあるんですよ
マンゴー果物になってくると甘い香りがあるんですけど
マンゴー木は自分でなんとか香り出してるんです
これが香りと言えるんでしょうかね
でもあれで結構落ち着くんです
香りでもないし 匂いでもないんですけど
微妙に落ち着くんです
そういうことだから 環境的にはね
遊びに行くためにちょっと一日ハイキングしようと思ったら
マンゴー林なんかあったらもう最高なんです
ただボケーっとしたっても結構気分がいいんです
そこでこの枝が結構大きい木だからね
いっぱいありまして そこでも木はああいう特色を持ってるんだから
もう鳥たちが来て もうあっちこっちで巣を作る
遊ぶ 回るんですよ 鳥たちもどこかで餌を食べて
では遊ぶぞと言ったら
これもうもう遊園地なんですね
鳥たちの 鳥たち 鳥たちと
もう猿もたまたま来るんですけど
ちょいちょい全部葉っぱ食べますけどね
で来るし だから環境って言えば本当にすごい
一応人間が作る植えるんですけど
一旦マンゴーですから
すごい自然が戻るということがあるんです
だからこの名義お坊さんもマンゴー林で瞑想しようと修行しようと行ったんですけど
うまくいかないんですね
瞑想が その環境で 気分よくなっちゃって
気分が良くなったということは
心はどうせ貪瞋痴でしかないでしょうに
だからすごい穏やかな気持ちになったということは
欲が出たという ああ 気分がいいなという欲なんです
そこで鳥たちが遊んでいるわ
見ているとなんか楽しくてたまらなくなっちゃうんです
巣を作ってヒナたちに餌を持ってくるわとかね
そこでチチチってキーキーって鳴きながら遊んだりするでしょうに
チラチラと見てしまうんです
そこで空気がものすごく清らかになっている空気でしょうに
で なかなか心が落ち着かなかったんです
瞑想は進めない もうやっぱり瞑想をやめてちょっと休もうという気持ちになるんです
瞑想をやめてやめるわけに休むわけにはいきませんし
自分がせっかく家を出て財産も捨てて出家しているのに
なんだこの心は こんなに揺れるんですかと
なんでこんなに欲の思考が現れるんですかと
お坊さんだからそれは欲だと知ってるんです
でもあの美しい風景を見ないではいられない
すぐ見ちゃってしまう
瞑想しても何かああいう綺麗な声なんか耳に入っちゃうと
また心がもう混乱してしまう
負けちゃったんです 負けて
すごく素直に正直にまたお釈迦様のところに行ったんです
行ってもう瞑想できんと
言ったところでお釈迦様はそれを教えてあげたんです
心っていうのはそういうものやと
ほんのちょっとのことで気分が変わるんだと
ちょっとあるつまらない鳥でもいいんですよ
灰色の小さくて それでも来て
雛にちっと鳴いて餌ちょっとあげただけでも
自分の心で欲が生まれてくる可能性あります
それだけでも あるいはその鳥が餌をあげてからくちばしを枝につけて掃除するでしょうに
小さなくちばしだから別にとったことない
それ見ただけでも ああ
なんと可愛いんでしょうかと
たったそれだけのことでも心が揺れるんですよ
そこで妄想しちゃうと
家族っていいものだなと
母親っていうのは本当にいかに愛情を持って子育てするんでしょうか？とかね
そういえば うちの家内も子供が小さい時と思っちゃうでしょうね
これで減速したくなるんです
今 子供は大人になって独立してるかもしれませんし
うちの家内はおばあさんになってるかもしれませんし
やっぱりうちの家内もその頃ね
本当に必死で子育てしたなとかね
立派なもんだなと やっぱり親切にしてあげなくちゃとか
私は感謝ぐらいも言わなかったねとかね
いう気持ちになるでしょ
妄想を働かせちゃうと
当たり前だと思っていたのに
とんでもないな私はと
一緒に感謝ぐらいしておけばよかったのに
そんなこと考えて瞑想できますかね
瞑想を出家する解脱するところじゃなくて
また家に戻りたくなっちゃうんです
原因はちょっとした小鳥なんか雛に餌あげたぐらいのことでしょうに
だからその心のこの微妙なところを見て
お釈迦様が心は揺れるんだ
不動だ 守り難いんだ いい方向へ持っていくのはとんでもない難しいんだと
だからやるんだよと だからやるんだよと言ったんです
それでもう機嫌直ったんですよ
あ なるほど そういうものにはめげないことがブッダの道であると
で それで修行 成功するんです
それからはね はぁ 疲れました
心について今日の話を覚えておけば
次 次の次の偈は早く終わります
一応今日はあの第三章でしたっけ？これの初めの偈だから
心についていくらか明確に説明しなくちゃいけない
それでもたくさん喋りましたけどね
まあ他の宗教では魂 霊魂という概念に
仏教では心ということを使ってますけど
でも全く同じものじゃない
魂っていうのは証明しているものではなくて
人間の前提として見ているものだから
それは実際しない 存在しないということは仏教でなっているんです
人間の妄想概念であると
しかし 心という機能がありまして
それは魂とは言えるものではなくて
ものすごくだらしないものになる
自我意識っていうのは心なんです
私がいるんだという気持ちは心なんです
それがだらしない ものすごく当てにならない
危険なものであって 尊いものってわけじゃなくて
それで解脱を説いてるんです
はい 終わりです  先生  はい
あの イダン・チッタンのですね
イダンですけども それはあの弱い心の方のことを言っているのか
それとも精進している心を言っているのか
ちょっとよくわからなかったんですけど
イダンね この心という意味ですよ
別に  はい で そのこのっていうのは
その最初のこの弱い心のことを言ってるんですか？ 弱い心でしょうね
パリパンダティ・ダンチッタン
この心はもう揺れてるんだよと
魔界を 魔界の領域を捨てるために揺れている
捨てるためじゃなくて捨てるべきであると
揺れていて捨てるべきである
なんで繋げるんですかね
別々にして下さい  別々ですか
うん 私は繋げて言ってないんですよ
だからと一言葉で繋げただけ
ずっときちんと別々に説明したはずなんです
心は揺れている この心は揺れていると
どうしようもないものであると
だから育てるべきですという
いいですか 中村先生の訳でですね
私も結構気になってたんですけど
この心は悪魔の支配から逃れ
逃れ 逃れようとしても起き回るっていう
そういう風に訳されてるんですね
逃れ？ この心は悪魔の支配から逃れようとしても起き回るって訳されてるんですよ
僕はどうもこの訳は納得いかなかったんですね
あの 支配から逃れようとはしてないかと
それはどうでもいい 私にとっては関係ない話で
中村さんは だからそれは皆様の問題で
私はどんな訳したっても中村さんの訳だからといって私の説明は捨てるでしょうし
それはどうでもいいんですけど
パーリ語ではパハータウェっていうのは何でしたっけ？動詞は
パハラティですね  ん？それでどんな動詞ですか？そのパハータウェっていうのは
打つとか 打つという意味
ん？ 打つという意味が書いてあったんですけどね
打つ？ パハラティっていう
パハラティではない これは殴るっていう意味で
それ その意味じゃない動詞は
捨てるって意味なんです
捨てるという動詞なんです
パハータッバン・パジャハティ
打つって これはパハーラなんです
アー入ります パハータウェといえば
このサプタミという動詞のやり使い方で捨てるべきであるという
捨てるのである 捨てるものであろうというニュアンスなんです
中村さんの訳を通用するためには
パハー・イトゥンという風に偈を書き換えなくちゃいけないんです
ワーリジワタレーキット・オーカモーカトッバト・パリパンダリタン
パリパンダリタン・チッタン・マーラデイヤン・パハー・イトゥンという風に
そんなのはもう残酷でできるはずないでしょうね
ダンマパダの偈っていうのはもう決まってるんだから
これは誰にも変えることはできません
とにかくパハータウェっていうのは
まあ捨てるべきであるというね
えーと 何かご質問ありますか？はい
どうぞ  すみません あの
目とか鼻とか鼻じゃあ目から情報が入ってきて
脳の中で組み立てていることを私たちは意識という形であの
それが現実というか あの
思ってるっていう風にあの長老おっしゃったと思うんですけど
その脳の働きと心というのは一緒のものなんですか
さっきから言ってる心っていうのと
脳の働き で あの脳は肉体の一部ですね
仏教から見れば 肉体っていうのはいろいろ部品に分けちゃって
自分でいろいろ仕事してるんで
心臓は心臓の仕事 肺は肺の仕事で
それでこの電気信号をあっちこっちに張り巡らせ巡らせるのは
まあ脳という まあ臓器の仕事な
まあ臓器で見てるんですよ
心っていうのはその機能の生きているという機能のことなんです
じゃあこう見て まあ目を通してどう結んだっていう機能は脳の仕事で
それについて長老だ ブッダの像だ
なんだ あれがいいとかっていうのが心っていう風に思ってるんですか
うーん あまりこの脳 我々の心は一応脳の中ですごい働きますけど
脳イコール心ではないんです
脳イコール心だったら
もう人が死んでも脳があるんだからね
死ぬっていうかどういうことでしょうかね
体全体の機能停止でしょ
だから体全体の機能が心なんです
なかなか心は何やっていう風に掴めるっていうことは難しいんです
なぜならば 我々は物質的に考えてるんですよ
我々の物質しか認識はっきり理解できない状態もあります
心っていうのも 目に見えないものじゃなくて
何か物質として考えているということですか
いけないと言っていることです
それはいけない  そうそうそう
心を物質化してはいけない
そうそう うん  そうすると機能という
あの目に見えないものを心という風に言ってるんですか？ 目に見えないって言ったら聞こえもないんですけど
だから見える 見るということが心なんです
聞こえるということが心の機能なんです
生きるということも心の機能
だから機能に言ってるんですね
だから機能は見えるか見えないかっていう話じゃないんですよ
機能は見えませんよ 例えば車動くの見えると思ってるでしょ？見えません
車が見えるだけ 動きは見えません
だから物質な世界でも機能は見えないんです
だからそんな難しく考えません
仏教はね 例えば誰か手を刺したと
「あ 痛い」と思うでしょうね
それが心なんです その瞬間の痛みは
それで気分 気持ちも悪くなるでしょうね 「
何するんでしょうか」と
それも心なんで それで次の人をやって 「
あんたの手がすごく可愛いね」とか言うでしょうに
そうするとパッとあの気持ちが変わっちゃって
すごく気分が良くなるでしょ
それも心なんです そうやってもうもう当てにならないほど
もう瞬時に瞬時に変わっていく
その機能に心と呼ぶんです
だから心 心っていう風に取れないっていうことは僕ははっきりするんです
取ってもいけない 取ったお坊さんの話は
あの 木のある一つのものを取っただけで
お釈迦様に捨てられたんです
人そのものを あの前言ったでしょ
エピソードは サーティットお坊さんの
それぐらい厳しいですよ
でも心を発見する法ってあるんです
簡単に で 体が正真正銘の物体だとまず理解する
それは理解しやすい はっきりした物体だ
その場合はこの壁 机 椅子
床 絨毯 座布団 全部物質でしょ
それと全く同じ物質だと
それは別に変な考えたりではありませんよ
体はまるっきり物質だと
この座布団と同じだと
というと 「では座布団と体は何が違うのか」と
その違うところは全部心なんです
座布団には見えません
体には見える 心です 座布団ぶん殴ったっても
そのまんま何の反応もない
この物体をぶん殴っちゃうとえらく反応するんです
ものすごく それは心の働き
だから心見えないんですけど
心の働きは認識できる
その働きをまとめて まあ言葉として心という単語を使う
そこで自己消滅 自動処理するでしょ
この物体は